digamos que tengo a james igual a 7
elevado a la equis cuadrada menos x
cuál es la derivada de con respecto x y
de nuevo te invito a que pausa este
vídeo e intentes encontrarla bien
observa cómo está coloreado esto y tal
vez inmediatamente reconozcas que ésta
es una función compuesta la puedes ver
de la siguiente manera ésta es una
función compuesta si te tomas primero a
la función btx y ésta sea igual a 7
elevado a la equis y también puedes
tomarte esta otra función la función de
x igual a equis cuadrada menos x
entonces lo que tenemos aquí es quien es
igual a 7 elevado a la algo no puedes
ver decir que es igual a b d y ojo no es
vez de x es b d y de x
en lugar de una equis tenemos aquí a de
equis a toda la función de equis y la
regla de la cadena nos dicen que la
derivada de llegó en respecto a x que
por cierto hay varias formas de
escribirlo la derivada de ye con
respecto a x va a ser igual a b prima de
de x de de x por prima de x ésta es una
forma de escribirlo o también puedes
decir que la derivada de que con
respecto a x es igual a la derivada de b
con respecto aún por la derivada de con
respecto a x de cualquier manera que lo
veas vamos a aplicar la regla de la
cadena por aquí y entonces me va a
quedar tienes b prima de 1 quien es la
derivada de b con respecto a um bueno ya
sabemos y esto lo vimos en vídeos
pasados lo acabamos de probar que si pd
x es igual a 7 elevado a la x entonces b
prima de x va a ser igual al logaritmo
natural de 7
que multiplica a 7 elevado a la equis en
vídeos pasados probamos la derivada de
funciones exponenciales con bases
distintas a en entonces la derivada de
ya con respecto a x va a ser igual a el
logaritmo natural de 7 que multiplica a
7 y en lugar de poner 7 elevado a la x
recuerda
estamos tomando b prima de de x entonces
me quedaría 7 elevado a la x cuadrada
menos x y luego tenemos que multiplicar
eso por la derivada de u con respecto a
x pero quién es la derivada de v
respecto a x tiene su prima de x la
derivada de x cuadrada es 2x y la
derivada de menos x es menos 1 entonces
a todo esto lo vamos a multiplicar por 2
x menos 1 y ahí lo tienes
esta es la derivada de que con respecto
a x y puedes intentar reescribir esto o
expresar lo de diferentes maneras pero
lo importante que hay que recalcar aquí
si vamos a tomar la derivada de 7
elevado a la u de x entonces nos tomamos
la derivada de 7 elevado a la x con
respecto a x como aquí entonces sería el
logaritmo natural de 7 por 7 elevado a
la potencia y en lugar de x ponemos de x
tomamos esto y lo multiplicamos por la
derivada de v es decir prima de x y al
final todo esto fue simplemente aplicar
la regla de la cadena